Pengkomputeran bertanggungjawab difahami
sebagai membangunkan quantum computing
dengan kesedaran tentang kuasanya
dan potensi kesannya. Bila kita cakap tentang tanggungjawab,
kita perlu membangun dan menggunakan teknologi
berdasarkan prinsip yang telah ditetapkan untuk bantu kita elak
dan kurangkan potensi bahaya,
sambil mempromosikan penyelesaian yang secara proaktif
inklusif dan bertanggungjawab. Di IBM,
kami telah didorong oleh rasa tanggungjawab
kepada masyarakat selama berdekad-dekad. Hari ini kami menggelar diri kami sebagai pemangkin
yang membuatkan dunia berfungsi dengan lebih baik. Ini bermakna kami
ada tanggungjawab untuk pertimbangkan implikasi
teknologi yang kami bina dan bantu guna pakai.
Semasa kami membangunkan teknologi baru ini,
keputusan yang kami buat hari ini akan membentuk masa depan,
dan keputusan-keputusan ini
berpotensi untuk memberikan kesan besar kepada masyarakat.
Contohnya, kamu mungkin perlu putuskan sama ada nak kejar aplikasi
yang hanya bantu segelintir pihak berkepentingan, atau
satu yang mungkin boleh selesaikan masalah masyarakat.
Kami harap kamu sebagai klien boleh berfikir
tentang pembangunan quantum computing secara bertanggungjawab, supaya
berfikir secara bertanggungjawab boleh bantu bisnes kamu bina kepercayaan
dengan pelabur dan pengguna,
sekaligus membina reputasi integriti
dan penghormatan dengan pekerja kamu
dan pelanggan. Di sisi lain,
ia boleh bantu lindungi kamu daripada publisiti buruk, denda,
dan penalti. Dalam video ini,
kami akan perkenalkan pertimbangan tanggungjawab yang penting
untuk dibincangkan dengan pasukan kamu
semasa kamu meneroka quantum computing
dan aplikasinya. Bila bercakap tentang quantum computing,
berfikir dan bertindak secara bertanggungjawab
bermakna mengikuti satu set prinsip
dan nilai untuk pandu pembangunan
dan penggunaan teknologi kamu.
Contohnya, ini bermakna kamu perlu telus
tentang batasan dan keupayaan
quantum computing hari ini. Kami ada bahasa
dalam kontrak kami yang mewajibkan klien IBM Quantum
menggunakan sistem kami secara bertanggungjawab,
dan mereka tidak boleh guna sistem kami
untuk tujuan jahat atau haram.
Kami gelar ini sebagai klausa penggunaan bertanggungjawab
dan penggunaan yang boleh diterima.
Bahasa ini dah pun mempengaruhi cara klien kami berfikir
tentang membangunkan quantum
untuk kes guna mereka. Kami boleh
turut membantu pengaruhi hala tuju quantum computing
dengan memutuskan aplikasi mana yang kami kejar
untuk pembangunan dan pecutan.
Bagi melindungi daripada potensi penggunaan yang tidak bertanggungjawab
terhadap teknologi kami, kami juga dah bangunkan teknologi IBM Quantum
yang selamat dan teguh. Bila kamu fikir tentang bagaimana
dan untuk apa nak guna quantum computing,
pastikan kamu bercakap secara realistik tentang jangkaan kamu
untuk quantum computing dan jangka masa
yang kamu harap untuk menggabungkan quantum.
Jangan gambarkan quantum computing
sebagai sesuatu yang misteri. Sebaliknya, cuba jelaskan ia secara realistik
sebagai perkakasan pengkomputeran
yang mengikuti peraturan fizik kuantum.
Pastikan kes guna kamu untuk quantum computing
adalah inklusif secara proaktif
dan mengambil kira semua pihak berkepentingan yang berpotensi,
untuk tentukan sejauh mana
kesan negatif kepada masyarakat.
Pastikan kamu ada prinsip yang jelas
dan nilai untuk penerangan kes guna kamu
dan pembangunannya. Terima kasih
kerana menonton. Kami harap
semasa kamu membawa quantum computing yang berguna ke dunia,
kamu juga akan fikirkan bagaimana nak buat ini secara bertanggungjawab.
The the